[Música]
hola bienvenidos a revista digital donde
abordamos los temas más importantes del
ciberespacio las redes sociales y los
medios de comunicación de américa latina
y el mundo
brad voice es un grupo de extrema
derecha de estados unidos y la comunidad
lgtb
alrededor del mundo se encargó de ahogar
cualquier publicación relacionada con
ellos en twitter miles de usuarios
tomaron este nombre para compartir
publicaciones alusivas al orgullo gay e
invisibilizar en esta plataforma
cualquier mensaje asociado con el odio
cuál fue su motivo aquí se los
explicamos empezamos
el número del prd boys chicos orgullosos
en español volvió a ser tendencia en
twitter pero esta vez con un giro
positivo miles de hombres homosexuales
en todas partes del mundo especialmente
en eeuu se adueñaron de la etiqueta e
inundaron la red social con imágenes que
se le abran el orgullo gay su objetivo
era invisibilizar las publicaciones de
odio asociadas con la organización de
extrema derecha que se hace llamar proud
voice cuyos integrantes registran un
largo historial de violencia e
intimidación
usando esta etiqueta los usuarios
compartieron fotografías con sus parejas
y contaron sus historias de amor de la
misma forma homenajearon a figuras gays
la iniciativa que se cree fue promovida
por el actor george takei tuvo gran
acogida no sólo entre celebridades sino
también entre organizaciones defensoras
de derechos humanos y hasta en la armada
canadiense en eeuu también se creó una
página web llamada de proud voice punto
key y en ella se recopilaron todas estas
publicaciones
y sabemos lo que significa el verdadero
orgullo éstos debiluchos que necesitan
depender de las armas para hacer
cualquier cosa son falsos de artix y no
se han ganado lo que la palabra orgullo
denota
uy marchamos en desfiles del orgullo
porque estamos orgullosos discos with
around esta iniciativa el gti se dio
unos días después del primer debate
presidencial entre donald trump y joe
biden así como el presidente ha
criticado asociaciones de izquierda
esta vez fue presionado para que
condenara a los grupos de extrema
derecha por su papel en los episodios de
violencia en eeuu
esto en el marco de las manifestaciones
contra el racismo y la brutalidad
policial cuando se le pidió
explícitamente que condenara a los
propios a quienes se les ve portando
armas en las protestas sólo se limitó a
pedirles que retrocedieran y esperarán
su declaración generó una ola de
comentarios negativos en su contra pero
los miembros del grupo celebraron que el
presidente los mencionara un día después
trump cambió su versión el mandatario
dijo que no conocía a dicha organización
durante una entrevista a fox news
aseguró que condena a los pross voice y
a todos los supremacistas blancos sea
quienes sean ellos tienen que retirarse
y dejar que la publicidad de su trabajo
el movimiento generado por la comunidad
lgbt no sufrió ninguna contraofensiva
visible al menos en twitter puede que la
principal razón sea que esta red social
suspendió la cuenta oficial de brad
voice en 2018 así como la de su fundador
y otras asociadas a ella debido a que
infringían sus políticas de prohibir a
grupos extremistas violentos facebook
tomó una decisión similar el mismo año
citando violaciones a sus normas contra
los discursos de odio pero esto no ha
detenido a los integrantes del grupo que
ha cobrado fuerza en otras plataformas
como pearl air que es muy popular entre
los conservadores según informa la
revista forbes los prop voice están
furiosos porque la comunidad del gti se
apoderó de su numeral y que por ello han
inundado esta aplicación con mensajes de
odio de acuerdo con el medio de
comunicación al presidente del grupo
enrique tarrío de origen cubano dijo que
la izquierda estaba tratando de
convertir el nombre del grupo en un
insulto pero a la cadena cnn dijo lo
siguiente
esto no es algo que nos ofenda no es un
insulto no somos homofóbicos uno de los
mensajes que quieren enviar con esto es
que están tratando de ahogar a nuestros
seguidores están tratando de silenciar
nos cuando tratan de ahogar los
pensamientos de otras personas yo no
creo que haya nada progresista en eso
el nombre de los pross boyle se había
empezado a ir años atrás en medio de las
manifestaciones contra el racismo el
grupo fue fundado en 2016 y está
compuesto exclusivamente por hombres que
se autodenomina como chovinistas
occidentales es decir que exaltan
excesivamente lo nacional frente a lo
extranjero desde su creación han sido
criticados por su retórica misógina anti
musulmana y anti inmigrante
una organización defensora de los
derechos civiles calificó a los pross
voice en 2018 como un grupo de odio el
mismo año el fbi y los clasificó como un
grupo extremista con vínculos con el
nacionalismo blanco aunque cabe resaltar
que no todos sus integrantes son blancos
de acuerdo con la liga antidifamación
una organización religiosa el grupo
puede tener cientos de miembros con
presencia en varios estados del país y
hasta en reino unido noruega y australia
los medios de comunicación de distintas
partes del mundo se han encargado de
justificar el propósito de esta campaña
el portal huffington post titula hombres
gays secuestran el hashtag de proud
voice en una poderosa campaña en redes
sociales por su parte el diario italiano
la repubblica señaló que más que un
secuestro lo que la comunidad del gti
quiere señalar es una reapropiación del
término pride orgullo en español que es
parte de su cultura el portal
estadounidense bus fit news dice que
dada la inclinación del grupo por una
cierta marca de masculinidad blanca la
decisión de usar la etiqueta con
imágenes de hombres homosexuales no es
sólo un reclamo sino una provocación
descarada la versión alemana de la
cadena deutsche welle mencionó casi de
manera jocosa que si el presidente de
donald trump abre twitter y busque el
numeral proud voice difícilmente verá
tweets sobre el grupo y que en cambio
encontrará o se encontrará con numerosos
usuarios que expresan quiénes son los
verdaderos chicos orgullosos hombres
homosexuales que viven abiertamente su
homosexualidad
hasta aquí y revista digital recuerde
que si quiere repetir esta u otra
emisión de nuestro programa lo puede
hacer a través de nuestra página web www
punto frente 4 punto com
[Música]